régis de castelnau bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france eric
dupond-moretti nouveau garde des sceaux
alors certains sont surpris du fait de
sa personnalité controversée
d'autres évoquent le bien fondé de
nommer un avocat à la tête de ce
ministère quel est votre regard
écoutez surprise oui c'est tout à fait
incontestable
alors je crois qu'il faut voir le
problème sous trois angles premièrement
qu'à chercher emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron il avait un problème avec madame
b to b qui est probablement un des pires
garde des sceaux de l'histoire de la
république et donc il fallait qu'ils
trouvent une solution mais il n'y a pas
eu grand monde pour se porter candidat
et comme d'habitude monsieur macron a
joué la carte de la communication la
carte un petit peu de la société du
spectacle comme il le fait avec roselyne
bachelot à la culture il a proposé sa à
eric dupond moretti
est ce que il faut y voir beaucoup de
sens politique en particulier à partir
des analystes font par exemple les
syndicats de magistrats actuellement je
pense pas un je pense pas je crois que
c'est surtout une opération de
communication alors il ya un deuxième
problème qui est du point de vue d'eric
dupond moretti c'est un grand avocat
c'est incontestable un combattant hors
norme mais incontestablement qui a
depuis trois ans était un petit peu
normalisée il a beaucoup adouci son
discours et je veux dire je m'interroge
un petit peu sur cette consécration qui
est par l'attribution du poste et
peut-être pas par la mise en place de
réformes importantes alors nommer un
avocat à ce poste c'est pas la première
fois loin de là contrairement à ce que
j'entends beaucoup
il ya eu bien évidemment le précédent de
robert badinter mais ce serait je veux
dire assez normal de dire que dupont
moretti et badinter ne joue pas dans la
même cour
troisième observation c'est quand même
que le chantier est colossal s'est pas
seulement les réformes que vous avez
indiqué qu'ils sont importants tels que
personne maintenant j'aurais tendance à
soutenir mais de trouver les solutions
pour éviter ce qui est en cours c'est à
dire une clochardisation de la justice
donc eric dupond moretti est à beaune
avocats eric dupont moretti était très
présent et dans les médias ici
débrouille très bien être le patron
d'une grande administration d'un des
grands ministères régaliens cet autre
chose et il va falloir qu'ils aillent à
bercy et pour essayer de trouver les
moyens budgétaires de redresser cette
justice malheureusement avec un premier
ministre et un président de la
république tous deux issus de l'ena et
dans une grande proximité avec
l'administration de bercy
les arbitrages sont seront toujours
rendue en faveur de bercy c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je lui souhaite
bon courage j'espère que l'on va
assister à une réussite mais j'ai des
gros doutes
justement à votre avis quelles vont-être
ses priorités c'est très difficile de le
savoir d'abord je veux dire il ya la
priorité budgétaire il ya la question de
la retraite des avocats qui sont des
pommes de discorde tout à fait
considérable si vous voulez pour le
praticien la justice étant très très
mauvais état ensuite il ya le problème
posé par les dérives auxquelles on a
assisté depuis trois ans et en
particulier depuis le mois de juin
concernant la politisation de cette
justice ça c'est un problème très
important
est ce qu'il ya une diplomatie est
décidé à s'attaquer à cet aspect des
choses
1 par exemple avec la séparation
radicale du parquet et des juges du
siège qui serait une très bonne solution
qui est personnellement ma position je
pense que ce sera probablement pas
suffisant à ce sera pas suffisant parce
que d'abord il va être très mal
accueillie par les par les magistrats
lille ceci aujourd'hui sont assez
déterminée et je ne vois pas renoncer à
ce qui s'est passé regarder juste un
petit exemple
il avait déposé à juste titre une
plainte contre x pour les écoutes
incroyable dont il a fait l'objet et le
suivi pendant six ans par le parquet
national financier de madame houlette a
donc c'est un scandale par semaine
concernant cette institution créée il
faut le rappeler par françois hollande
est bien une première chose qui fait et
c'est annoncé par l'elysée ce qui n'est
pas à mon avis dû au hasard
première chose qui fait il retire sa
plainte donc voilà je pense que je sais
pas si c'est comparable à un plat de
lentilles mais ça y ressemble un peu
quand même donc je crois que il l'a
sûrement des priorités il a peut-être
envie de laisser sa trace mais enfin
c'est déjà d'ores et déjà une concède
une consécration et de toute façon il a
un peu plus de 18 mois de mandat devant
lui puisque après il y aura la
présidentielle de 2022
je doute que nous ayons une révolution
un qui serait pourtant malheureusement
nécessaire
sa personnalité son franc parler mais
aussi sa notoriété vous paraissent ils
compatibles avec emmanuel macron oui oui
je pense je pense que ils sont issus de
deux mondes très différents
emmanuel macron ne s'intéressent pas à
la politique emmanuel macron administre
le pays
il a certes un mépris c'est connu pour
le monde politique
il y nomme des gens qui n'en sont pas
issus comme les rives dupond-moretti par
exemple donc je pense pas que ça puisse
mal se passer
un jour je crois que emmanuel macron
continuera sa trace il n'y aura pas de
je vois pas qui dédient y ait des
possibilités de problème
eric dupond moretti a mis beaucoup d'eau
dans son vin depuis trois ans beaucoup
il a un peu je veux dire ceux perdus ce
caractère offensif c'est peut-être l'âge
en tout cas il s'est dit c'est dont je
ne vois pas de souci de cette nature la
réforme devrait des retraites sera l'un
des grands chantiers de ce nouveau
gouvernement
comment imaginez vous quelle quelle
réponse quel type de réponse peut-il
avoir face à la colère des avocats
justement à propos de cette réforme
écoutez je lui souhaite du courage
parce que la réforme est purement et
simplement spoliés à thouars ça c'est
tout à fait incontestable les avocats
qui avait beaucoup soutenu faut le
rappeler emmanuel macron demande
judiciaire dans son ensemble magistrats
et avocats avaient soutenu l'arrivée
d'emmanuel maquereau au pouvoir en 2010
est un set l'alliance elle est rompue
aujourd'hui il ya une énorme défiance
vis-à-vis de la présidence d' emmanuel
macron comment eric dupond-moretti n'a
pas tout à fait le profil de quelqu'un
qui raconte de quelqu'un qui met de
l'huile dans les rouages ne s'est pas
tout à fait sa méthode donc alors s'il y
avait une possibilité d'affrontements
avec les chefs de l'état c'est sur ce
point que ça aurait lieu mais
personnellement je pense qu'on n'ira pas
au clash
merci beaucoup régis de castelnau
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat animateur
du blog vue du droit